what's going on guys this is rob and a
lot of you really seem to enjoy the
videos that we did like we need to talk
about reed richards or we need to talk
about black bolt who sucks and so in
this video we need to talk about
she-hulk and maybe we'll make this uh a
weekly series right we have to talk
about the she-hulk trailer here's the
thing i'm excited for the she-hulk show
i really
really really am and this is our first
real look at it right the teaser we got
before was basically disney being like
it's a show that's happening and like
that was
it they were like the rumors are true it
exists uh
stay tuned for more info and that was
that was really all that we got but in
the most recent trailer that came out we
got what looks like a pretty solid
indicator of what the show is about and
here's the thing man i know that like
wong is going to appear in the show and
i know that like obviously mark
ruffalo's incredible hulk is going to
appear in the show i mean honestly based
on the comics of what it looks like with
the trailer things like that like their
histories are directly intertwined the
funny thing about this is it's going to
be kind of cool to see them but i'm not
like overly anticipated about them right
it's not like i'm looking at it like oh
yes we get to see mark ruffalo's hulk
again i'm not really all too worried
about that and it doesn't really have
anything to do with the fact that i
wasn't a big fan of professor hulk i
didn't really mind it it was fine i
think infinity war in avengers inn game
was a hugely missed opportunity to give
us world breaker hulk but you know in
all honesty i'm looking forward more to
like jennifer walters and like
abomination and all that stuff because i
feel like abomination was just one of
those little unsung heroes from the mcu
that was just so interesting and so cool
that we just never got enough of right
like we literally saw him in the
incredible hulk movie with edward norton
and then as far as i'm aware we didn't
see him again until shang chi or shang
chi and then like that's it like it's
him and wong fighting in a dueling ring
and it's like i mean i kind of want to
see more of abomination man he's a cool
character and it looks like we're gonna
get to see him here in what capacity i'm
not entirely sure because as i
understand it titania is supposed to be
the main villain for she-hulk as opposed
to abomination but maybe he'll have some
kind of a bigger role in that again we
won't necessarily know how everything
unfolds until the show comes out now i
will admit after seeing the trailer
the cgi is a little questionable i mean
we can all kind of agree with that like
i mean you know
and that's one of the things
i'm not entirely sure why because it's
not as though this is like a cw type
thing
by the way have you guys seen
everything got the axe at cw right i
think like the flash is the only thing
that didn't get cancelled but like
everything else is on the chopping block
it's nuts and it's all just gonna get
whisked off to the hbo max app where
it'll just kind of probably have a
season and then just go away and never
come back again i don't know if that'll
ever be the case or not but as i
understand the discovery the chair the
the company that bought uh warner
brothers or however that whole deal is
working right the warner brothers
discovery merger that they want to move
it all over to their own individual app
it's a big gamble we'll see if it pays
off cotton but uh but nonetheless you
know i have no clue what their what
their grand plan is there which is kind
of nuts but nonetheless back on track
the cw shows are like notorious for
having subpar writing and even more
subpar cgi the flash
is pretty rough but the writing's not
bad and i just really kind of enjoy it
but with disney plus it's not really
that way right i mean with cw basically
the creators of the show go set up a
lemonade stand and then basically use
that money to
do their special effects and like
literally fund the entire show but
disney puts money behind their shows
right like look at wanda vision look at
loki even hawkeye there's money in there
and sure not every moment with cgi is
absolutely perfect but it's obvious
they're not running on a shoestring
budget so looking at she-hulk it's just
kind of like i mean i don't necessarily
know but it may be one of those things
where just the amount of money that has
to be spent in order to give us the
jennifer walters she-hulk persona so
consistently that that cost is just so
high that there was only so much money
they could spend there which kind of
makes sense to a degree right you don't
want to spend the kind of money on a tv
show that you would spend with like
infinity war or avengers in-game just
some massive blockbuster film you
wouldn't really invest that same kind of
uh that same kind of cash but
nonetheless outside of that it looks
cool it looks interesting more so than
that like jennifer walters is she-hulk
it looks like they nailed it because
here's the thing those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with she-hulk i mean
she's like a lot of comic book
characters sometimes she's written great
and sometimes she's written terribly if
you ever really want to see a story
where she-hulk just loses her
go check out avengers disassembled where
like she literally just flips out right
goes into what you could kind of call
her world breaker form and uh just goes
nuts right starts trashing avengers
manchester and all that kind of stuff
nowhere near the same level as like the
incredible hulk world breaker form but
she still goes on a rampage and it's
really cool to see but the the show
itself looks like it's borrowing hugely
from the john burn run which really
excites me so for those of you guys who
don't know about the john burn run
that's kind of like the landmark
she-hulk run right like the definitive
run for she-hulk in the same way that
jason aaron's thor god of thunder is
like the landmark run that's really the
the defining aspect of what they're
using for thor love and thunder that's
really what they're doing with she-hulk
right they're borrowing from john burns
run the reason why is because when
she-hulk was originally introduced to
marvel comics she was just a chick who
got a blood transfusion from bruce
banner and that's how she became
she-hulk and then unlike bruce she could
transform at will and still maintain her
mental faculty she wasn't able to do
that initially but once she was able to
gain control of herself it became a
hallmark of her character and one of the
big differentiating factors between
herself and bruce with john burns run
they basically turned her into a kind of
sex object right where they focused more
on her uh physical uh physical
appearance right how like how she was
drawn and designed to look very
attractive to young male readers and and
so on and so forth but there was a lot
of character development and there was a
lot of humor in there so it was just a
really really great blend you also added
the fact that like she was breaking the
fourth wall and it was really intriguing
which really asked the question is that
something that we're going to get
consistently in the show because
she-hulk did that before deadpool it's
one of the big hallmark kind of
with her characters why she's a legacy
character is because it's like yeah she
was breaking the fourth wall before
deadpool was so i'm curious to see if
that's something that we're gonna see in
the show now if i'm being honest with
you one of the best ways i think they
could do that is in house of cards style
if any of you guys ever ever saw a house
of cards from kevin spacey you know what
i'm talking about but back when netflix
before they decided they wanted to go
the direction of blockbuster have you
guys seen that netflix is going belly up
son it's almost kind of funny to watch
but uh when netflix was first launching
their original series house of cards was
like the first real one and kevin
spacey's character would actually break
the fourth wall consistently and offer
like exposition either informing you of
what he was doing in the show or the
significance of it what his motivations
were or like who other people are
different things along those lines i
could definitely see them doing that in
the she-hulk show where like she she
like breaks the fourth wall and
addresses the audience and things like
that it would really make it unique and
it'd be a great way to tie back into the
days of like the john burns she-hulk run
again not really sure we won't know
until the show comes out but by and
large from what i'm looking at in the
trailer man it looks solid it looks
absolutely amazing but the other part of
this that i'm really looking forward to
is of course titania because what i feel
like disney's doing with the she-hulk
show is they're giving attention to
villains that we would otherwise just
never see because there'd be no reason
there there'd be no reason to bring them
in i mean granted titania was originally
part of secret wars that's like where
she kind of gained her big thing
technically she was a bit of a precursor
to secret wars but that's where she
first appeared as far as i remember and
then you got her backstory later on down
the line where she ended up becoming
titania before the events of secret wars
and then was whisked off to battle world
and all that kind of stuff but it's cool
i think it's awesome that they're doing
that they're saying like there's
villains out there like titania who are
huge right they're just enormous and in
terms of their physical stature and
there they are easily able to go
toe-to-toe against she-hulk and kind of
give us these smaller guys that we just
would never see in a film because
honestly who's gonna go see an avengers
movie with the main villain is titania
no one's gonna go see that
right i mean the marvel cinematic
universe movies are kind of reserved for
like the big time folks right the huge
name draws different things like that
you know it's not really a place for
like the smaller characters and so being
able to see the smaller villains in tv
form is cool because depending on how it
happens and on the how on how the
character is done they could roll them
in the other thing that i'm really
really excited about too that i'm really
hoping comes out of this is i'm really
hoping that depending on the popularity
of she-hulk and how well the show was
received by the general audience they'll
kick around the idea of putting her on
like the new avengers because one thing
to know is that she hulk she's had some
prominent roles in marvel comics there
was a point and i believe it was after
the original secret wars but i can't
remember off top my head my memory is a
little fuzzy on this this particular
thing i know i'm supposed to be the
expert but hey sometimes i forget stuff
i'm only human
but i believe after the events of secret
wars ben grimm chose to to either stay
behind or kind of go explore himself or
something like that and i believe she
hulk stepped in to replace ben grimm so
she was on the fantastic four for a
little while right she's been on
avengers team she's been on a bunch of
different teams i think she was on the
lady liberators i'm not going to swear
by that but i do know she was on a force
and a force was a great team oh my god
an all-female avengers team that story
was amazing i loved a force oh my god it
was part of secret wars uh 2015 one of
the tie-in comics it was absolutely
phenomenal but uh but i'm really hoping
that like depending on the popularity of
this that she-hulk's not gonna be just
relegated to the tv show that instead
we're gonna be able to see the marvel
cinematic universe branch her out and
give her a more prominent role but again
it's all really just based on what
they're doing with the show it's all
really based on how the show progresses
on how how it unfolds and really more so
than that whether or not anybody's
interested in it because it's entirely
possible that the trailer looks
phenomenal the show itself is just kind
of like
you know and basically all the best
moments were in the trailer so i don't
know but i have faith in disney and
marvel but i have faith the show is
going to be pretty solid but as far as
it being like a legal comedy slash
slight drama type show i'm looking
forward to it i'm excited about it and i
think it's going to be a really really
fun experience so all we have to do is
wait uh let's see this is may 18th so
may june july august we gotta wait four
months
we gotta wait four months for this show
it's gonna kind of suck having to wait
that long for this show i'm not even
gonna lie because i'm really looking
forward to it but let me know what you
guys thought about the trailer down in
the in the comments section right let me
know what you guys thought because again
i loved it i thought it was cool and i'm
really excited to see it but that being
said we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i'll
catch you all later
peace